Deep in a refrigerated vault on the snowy
hillside of a remote island in the arctic
circle, a library of seeds may be humanity’s
only hope for botanical salvation.
Hi everyone, Crystal here for DNews with some
good news about the apocalypse.
It’s probably already here but the earth’s
plants may survive and through them, humans
could too.
If we draw an analogy between the apocalypse
and a rapid, mass extinction of the number
and variety of living things on Earth; we
may just be the middle of one.
Mass extinctions, like the one that killed
the Dinosaurs, are characterized by a narrowing
of biodiversity due to environmental change.
And some scientists say that’s happening
right now.
Estimates place the current rate of extinction
of plants and animals at anywhere from 100
to 1000 times faster than our recent geological
past, and this rate appears poised to increase
as 1) our globe continues to warm, 2) human
populations continue to expand, and 3) geographical
regions continue to be devastated by wars
and natural disaster.
Humans have been concerned about protecting
the earth’s biodiversity since biblical
times.
Why else would we have a story about animals
lining up 2 by 2 to be preserved on a giant
ark?
“Biodiversity” refers to the number and
variety of living species within an ecosystem.
And this variety, specifically among plants,
is crucial for human survival since plants
are the source of our nutrients and energy,
as well as providing shelter and the starting
point for many medicines.
Seed banks, like the Svalbard Global Seed
Vault, are one way to preserve the biodiversity
of commercially significant crops, and of
wild native plants.
These libraries of seeds can be used to reintroduce
species into existing habitats, or to strengthen
genetically depleted populations.
But, maintaining a one stop shop of viable
seeds can be costly and challenging.
Recognizing the need for a more secure, global
effort, an organization called The Crop Trust,
with support from many well known private
foundations, has stepped in.
Their most dramatic program maintains an enormous
warehouse with the capacity to house a cache
of 4.5 million varieties of seeds.
Located on a Norwegian island north of the
arctic circle, this vault is envisioned as
a fail safe; a back-up to smaller more local
seed banks.
And in fact, that is exactly how it is being
used.
The first and only seed withdrawal was made
by Syria who used seeds they had previously
deposited in Svalbard to reconstruct a seed
bank recently destroyed by civil war.
Currently, more than 864,000 species of plant
life from over 100 countries are being preserved
within the cold, dry interior of this vault.
And its contents are estimated to approach
half of the known macroflora like trees and
grains, on the planet.
As this is a global project with diplomatic
implications, concerns over seed ownership
have naturally arisen.
For now, the vault acts as a high tech storage
facility, filtering out possible genetic duplications
in deposits but also ensuring that only the
original depositor will have access to their
contribution.
This restriction is to protect the library
of heirloom seeds from exploitation and for-profit
manipulation by biotech companies or agribusiness.
Not everyone agrees that locking up the seeds
to every known plant on earth is the way to
go.
Some critics say, libraries like these are
just historical records, offering simply a
snapshot in evolutionary time, and that the
plants preserved by this method would have
a low chance of survival after reintroduction.
Plants resulting from the preserved seeds
wouldn’t have had a chance to evolve with
the demands of their environment and they
may lack resistance to modern pests and disease.
Opponents of the seed bank approach often
focus on commercial crops and advocate for
preservation of seed diversity in the fields.
This in situ preservation requires the long-term
cooperation of farming communities to cultivate
a variety of the same crops over generations.
But, for example, with emphasis on profit,
it seems unlikely farmers would be able or
willing to keep growing every known variety
of corn if they were only making big money
on one.
Debate continues as to which path is best.
Large libraries of genetic diversity like
the Svalbard Global Seed Vault inspire the
imagination.
Will astronauts of the future be eating ancient
forms of terrestrial plants that just happen
to survive the demands of space?
The existence of home grown lettuce on the
International Space Station says “maybe”.
Certainly, select microflora like cyanobacteria
will have a one way ticket to Mars when the
time comes.
Evolution needs a starting point, and whether
it is a seed bank or a library of biodiversity
with galactic significance, when it comes
to life, more is better.
And may the best seed win.